una respuesta a Putin desde Polonia el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
dio un discurso de balance a días del
primer aniversario del inicio del
conflicto en Ucrania habló de la
fortaleza de la otan de una cumbre en su
país para 2024 de crímenes contra la
humanidad de futuras sanciones y se
refirió directamente a Putin
los autócratas solo entienden una
palabra y es el no no no no
no no van a tomarse mi país No van a
tomarselos a libertad ni nuestro futuro
Ucrania nunca será una victoria para
Rusia nunca
horas Antes había hablado Vladimir Putin
frente al parlamento ruso agradeció el
Patriotismo de sus ciudadanos por apoyar
la operación militar especial suspendió
el tratado de armas nucleares New Start
el último tratado importante de control
armamentístico firmado con Washington
avisó de que reanudarán pruebas
nucleares y Estados Unidos lo hace y le
dijo a occidente que Rusia no será
derrotada
haremos todo lo posible para traer de
vuelta a esta nuestra tierra la tan
ansiada Paz para brindar seguridad a la
gente a nuestros antepasados por el
futuro de nuestros hijos y nietos por la
justicia histórica por la reunificación
de nuestro pueblo nuestros Héroes que
hoy luchan el resto del mundo en alerta
ante el choque y el Renacer de Los
Fantasmas del pasado desde Naciones
Unidas pidieron a los dos países volver
a New Star y otros acuerdos
lo que sí sabemos es que es vital tener
un compromiso continuo de alto nivel
entre las dos potencias nucleares más
poderosas del mundo
La amenaza de la guerra nuclear se
mantiene un año después del inicio de la
invasión con el miedo a una nueva
escalada y competiciones de buscar una
salida al conflicto